whoa brad is telling me that cnn uh ceo
jeff zucker has just resigned is that
true
holy [ __ ]
we're winning guys do you get it yet
we're actually winning the thing is
crumbling and we're going to have an
incredible opportunity now that is
incredible news is it too early for the
tequila is it wow hot damn
oh it was announced 15 minutes ago over
an inappropriate work place relationship
oh lord lordy lordy did he say something
dirty to stelter who knows here's a memo
from zucker that's just coming out i'm
just reading this on the fly guys as
part of the investigation into chris
cuomo's tenure at cnn i was asked about
a consensual relationship with my
closest colleague someone i have worked
with for more than 20 years i
acknowledge the relationship
the relationship evolved in recent years
i was required to disclose it when it
began but i didn't i was wrong and as a
result i am resigning today
all right it sounds like we don't know
who the colleague is it doesn't sound
like this involves sexual harassment or
rape or whatever maybe this is a little
bit of a technicality
look again these things where it's like
we're all human beings we all have
relationships we've all made mistakes
we've all done stupid things in our past
i can't believe i'm not even defending
jeff zucker and i obviously need to know
more about this and i think jeff zucker
stepping down is good because he's led
putting aside whatever happened here
he's led cnn down a really really
horrible path um where they no longer
are journalism and they were something
roughly approximating journalism for a
long time so it's probably good that
he's stepping down in the name of
journalism or at least for the sake of
journalism um but this thing where it's
like we're all gonna look into
everybody's past and you made a pass at
somebody at a bar way back when and you
said that thing about that person and
you did that thing it's like man unless
we all want to live in glass houses we
better watch out